今日1ドクター始めたお前たち今日は何の日か知ってるか
7月7日七夕の日でございますただまだ7月なのひっかく空とは何の日かというご説明
しますと
あれ寿司工房子様とその女彦星様っ
こんな織姫が中国コバシサワットその織姫の女の2人がですねっねちょっとちゃんとし
た
ねずみ織姫はいえめんどくせぇとば取れた織姫さまで少し様がちょっと神様がね
ちょっと色々ありまして2人の仲を引き裂いたんですよ
もう会えないように神様が川をつくって2人が合えないようにしたんですよ
なんていうことだでも神様はまあねに一度だけねこの2人お互いを愛し合ってるんで
神様で年に1度だけ7月長田左
てその皮を年功に2人が技れるように寿司釣るんですよ
あってるか不安になってきたどんな感じの話せて気がするぞ
織姫と彦星は天ノ川を渡り1年に1度
ベイトを楽しむことができるのですよつまりこの愛する二人は1年に1度の夜しか会え
ないんですめでたしめでたし
ウェダーゲーは名なくないんだよ
俺は愛してる二人の仲を引き裂く皮が許せないこれがこのする何とかしてあげないんだ
よ
現代の科学でこのドクターはじめが愛し合う二人の間を取り巻くためにアグける
カバーを作ります強いスローなこちら俺はなんとしてでも掘り姫としかも c 一緒に
生活してロスコ
銀行とりあえずある程度で混ぜると水の上を向人数はみたいに歩けるようになるんです
よダイラタンシーというらせです要するに僕はですね彼はを作りませは国一だよベンツ
で皮をつくってその川に小麦粉を50球喰らうバンド入れて彼は酒と歩けるまさにある
ですよ
milkyway ですよ天の川小麦粉を入れているくいろね
ベルギーで山のガーは
俺がしかもその代わりに来こぼすのためにみんなのために織姫のために夫妻と食べに
渡れるアマゾンを作ってやんよ
すべては
愛のためにという理由でですね越冬
たかりこ飾ったり粉と小麦粉ってなんか違うのかなおらずれましたなんで俺これ見せ
たらやばいぞ集まってや場所ミスったの小麦粉と片栗粉とは違ういやいや化したあっ
ちょっと待って小麦粉じゃねぇ
片栗粉だ
はあああああコレなに完全ミスったじゃんそーゆーのっ
もうずっと待ってくれよ僕の七夕の願いはただ一つこの技巧は返品したい
行くぞあえねーぞコラ町田にミスターマジミスター
この豪華で天がおつくっていこうと思いますあの絶対甘沼の水漏加入ラッシュダメなの
でマジでちょっとで濡らさない反省いこうと思いますよし完璧な床は誰でもマネもれて
も心配ないで車に強化されたので実際に雨なんかはんだね
括弧をつくっていく
すー
1級でなんとかですねアマ側の形はできました
実際に顔の水を作っていこうと思いますもちろん
宿星さまが抜けるようにな
うわぁは本ネタじゃない方で間に入れていきます
こんな感じがちょっとそれから触って異なるてにくっつかないんですよ
この感じをタッチで中だよ水なのにこれ
やっぱまだのカバーね走れそうな水は完成したのでこれはちょっとで量産していこうと
思います
ヘイおおぉすげぇうわーっ
今ならねーこのば月の上で走れるぞ
例えば国だった花だああああ
これこれ片付け大丈夫かなまだまだもっともっとたしますからね
第2弾を完成したところで早速
花はに入れていきましょう重い行くぞ
me
いいいい
の収集する廃墟ひとまず完成いたしました
こちらはですね私の手作り水の上は走れる雨動画はでございます
どうですかね
で車からこの水ので走ります沈んでるかどうかっていうのはもうこの足でわかりやすい
と思います
指が簡単に隠れると沈んでいるということ
もんでー
いただきます次
j
これウエコラこれね浮いてるいてほらねこれ
ん
外れてない走れてる走れてるん
ほら増えて抜いてるんだとばれよこれよえっ
沈んじゃったっ
はい
ああああああ
ん
タブ浅いからわかりづらいんだよ浅いからわかりづらいんでちょっと最後わけでお風呂
に全部食べてみます
沈むとも足首隠れるんじゃねぇクレーンにかけれるんでここでね
実際走られかどうかちょっと最後チェックいきます
つい
トゥ
まあ
しずらし玲奈もう他の沈まない室もない
えっ沈まないけど止まると
エンゼルんだよね